Data Science
is a 21st-century job.
Data just keeps coming.
There's more and more of it,
and we need more people
to process it
and draw conclusions.
My name is André Costa
and I work with Business
Intelligence at Gympass.
Originally
I grew up in Brasília.
I've played a lot
of videogames as a kid.
I've always loved technology
and dreamed
of being a programmer
to make my own
videogames.
I have a degree in Business
and I'm getting my 6th
Udacity Nanodegree.
I started studying
Introduction to Programming
to get a firm grasp,
and then I took
the Data Analysis
and the Machine Learning
courses.
Now I'm also taking the course
on Artificial Intelligence
in order to have a good grasp
of these subjects.
I came to São Paulo
after I was offered a spot
in the Sales Department
of Gympass.
Later I had the chance
to move over to BI,
because there was
an open spot.
I took it. I had the knowledge,
I had worked with that.
I thought:
"Why not go for it?"
I changed departments
a few weeks later.
I've worked in BI
ever since.
Gympass is still a very new
company.
That is why we experiment
a lot
and that's why we need
Data Science,
to understand what's going on
in each experiment
and draw conclusions
about the best way to act
in each of the new things
we try,
whether it is an expansion
in a new country,
or a new department
we'll create,
or a new kind of contract
we'll do.
I've made projects
for Gympass
where my Udacity courses
were of great help.
For instance,
I built a dashboard
that used several tables.
In order to gather
all this information in one place
the Udacity course on databases
served me well.
I also did a client
clustering analysis
for different
client profiles.
This clustering
model building
I learned at Udacity.
For my career
I want to work at the boundary
between Tech and Business
to try and unite
these two worlds,
draw useful conclusions
and with Data Science,
to move the world forward.